Now that we have this
recursive formulation,
we're ready to develop the algorithm.
Let's convince ourselves first
that the recursive formulation
would indeed involve some
needless recomputation.
Take the two top level partitions,
A B C times D E
on the one hand and
A B C D times E on the other.
Clearly, we will have to compute
the minimum cost of multiplying A B C
in the left problem.
But we are also going to have to
compute it on the right as well
since we need to pull D off
from this chain at some point.
And we end up doing all the work
involved in figuring out
how best to multiply A B C over again.
Fortunately for us,
there are only n choose 2 sub-problems.
So we can create a table, and
do the sub-problems in the right order.
The entries along the diagonal
are the base cases, which have cost 0.
The product of 1 matrix
doesn't cost anything, and
our goal is to compute this value
in the corner here, C 1 through n.
The cost of multiplying
matrices a1 through an.
Consider which subproblems
this depends on.
When K equals one, we're considering
these costs here, C11 and C2N.
When K equals two, we're considering
these problems here, C12 and C3N.
When K equals three,
we consider these and so forth.
In general, every entry depends on
all the elements to the left and
downwards of it.
There are many ways to linearize this
diagonal of dependence, but the most
elegant is to fill out the diagonals
moving towards the corner like this.
We'll let s indicate which
diagonal we're working on.
And then we will fill in
the diagonal entry by entry
from row 1 as far as it goes.
For this row and diagonal,
the column j will be equal to i + s.
And we compute the entry in the table
as the minimum of all the possible
splits of the subtree.
The last step, of course,
is just to return this final cost.
The binary tree that produced this
cost can be reconstructed from
the k that were chosen that
yielded these minimum values.
We just need to remember the split that
we used for each entry in the table.